안녕하세요, 수업에 오신 것을 환영합니다. 다시 한번 환영합니다. 제 이름은 데이비드 브라운이고, 이 수업은 독창적인 읽기, 쓰기, 문법 통합 수업이 될 것입니다. 여러분 모두 여기 와주셔서 기쁩니다. 모두 자리에 앉아주세요. 환영합니다.
안녕하세요, 헥터 학생. 잘 지내시나요?
네, 잘 지냅니다. 선생님은 어떠신가요?
저는 아주 잘 지내고 있습니다. 감사합니다.
환영합니다. 환영합니다.
감사합니다.
주장에 관한 수업을 선택하신 것을 확인했습니다. 오늘 수업에서 더 설득력 있게 되는 법을 배우고 싶으신가요?
네, 배우고 싶습니다. 사실 정말 배우고 싶어요, 왜냐하면 다른 언어를 말할 때 그것이 매우 중요한 일이기 때문입니다.
네, 이것의 기본적인 질문은 '우리는 무엇을 원하는가, 그리고 어떻게 그것을 얻을 수 있는가?'입니다. 그리고 의사소통은 우리가 원하는 것을 얻는 수단입니다.
그래서 설득력 있게 되는 법을 배우는 것은 정말 놀라운 소프트 스킬입니다.
그리고 효과적으로 설득하기 위해 우리가 따를 수 있는 절차들이 있습니다. 그래서 오늘 수업에서는 효과적으로 설득하는 방법과 공식적으로 설득하는 데 도움이 될 수 있는 몇 가지 문법, 읽기, 쓰기 과제에 대해 이야기할 것입니다.
우리에게는 'cohesion'(응집성)이라는 개념이 있는데, 응집성이란 무언가가 전체적으로 완전한 상태를 의미합니다.
좋은 주장을 하기 위해서는 주장의 모든 부분을 갖추어야 합니다.
그리고 또한 주장이 매끄러워야 합니다. 흐름이 있어야 하죠. 그래서 우리에게는 'cohesion'(응집성)과 'flow'(흐름)라는 두 가지 개념이 있는데, 오늘 이것들에 대해 조금 이야기할 것입니다.
그럼 어떻게 이것을 달성할 수 있는지 탐구해 봅시다.
자, 화면에 이미지가 하나 있습니다. "뒤죽박죽인 아이디어에서 명확하고 설득력 있는 요점으로"라고 되어 있네요.
지저분한 방에 있는 이 남자를 볼 수 있습니다.
거기 커튼이 찢어져 있네요.
그리고 그곳은 깨끗해 보이게 만듭니다.
사실 제 방처럼 보이네요.
네, 네.
우리의 주장은 이와 같습니다, 그렇죠?
우리의 주장은 지저분할 수도 있고, 정리될 수도 있습니다.
그리고 만약 우리의 주장이 정리된 방식으로 제시된다면, 우리는 사람들이 무언가가 사실이라고 설득할 가능성이 더 커집니다.
우리는 이것을 진정성 있게 하고 싶습니다. 어떻게 하면 설득력 있는 요점을 만들기 위해 우리의 아이디어를 진정성 있게 정리할 수 있을까요?
주장에 대해 기억나는 것이 있는지, 아니면 설득에 대해 알고 있다고 생각하는 것을 말해주세요.
기억나는 주장의 두 가지 부분은 무엇인가요?
특정 부분을 기억하시나요?
사실, 기억이 안 나요.
아시다시피, 그렇게 체계적인 거요.
그리고 다른 하나는...
'정리된'이라고 말씀하셨죠.
그리고 '지저분한'.
네.
그리고 반대는 '정리된'이겠죠, 그렇죠?
그래서 정리된 것 대 지저분한 것이죠.
주장의 구조는 어떤가요?
어떻게 효과적으로 주장하나요?
좋은 주장을 하기 위해 해야 할 일은 무엇인가요?
음, 사실, 저는 그것을 매우 포괄적으로 만들어야 합니다.
그렇죠? 그 사람을 위해서요.
하나의 주장을 듣는 거죠. 그렇죠?
그리고 그것은 쉬워야 합니다.
이해하기에요.
그리고 이해하기도 쉬워야 하고요.
동의합니다.
그래서 만약 우리가 응집성이나 흐름과 같은 문법의 일부 측면을 개선한다면, 이해하기 더 쉽게 만들 수 있습니다.
우리는 그것을 지저분하지 않고 정리되게 만들 수 있습니다.
그리고 우리는 그것을 완전하게 만들 수 있습니다. 포괄적으로 만들 수 있죠.
이것들이 오늘 수업의 학습 목표입니다.
이 첫 번째 목표를 읽어주시겠어요?
네, 오늘의 학습 목표요.
구조와 흐름을 위해 모범 주장을 분석하기.
전부 다 읽을까요?
네.
주장을 구성하기 위해 시각적 정리 도구를 활용하기.
문법적 선택이 명확성에 어떻게 영향을 미치는지 이해하기.
그리고 응집성.
전환 어구를 효과적으로 사용하는 연습하기.
그리고 주장의 명확성에 영향을 미치는 흔한 오류를 식별하고 수정하기.
좋습니다, 여기 이 두 단어를 연습해 봅시다.
이것은 이렇게 발음합니다. 따라 해보세요. clarity, clarity.
아, clarity.
네.
그리고 이것은 Z와 같은 Jen 소리가 납니다.
ZJ 같은 소리죠. cohesion.
Cohesion과 clarity.
네.
네, 그게 그런 줄 몰랐어요.
clear와 같은 단어라는 것을요.
사실 헷갈렸어요.
네, clear라는 단어와 관련이 있습니다.
그래서 clear.
네, 관련이 있죠.
같은 것이죠.
그렇죠.
저는 그렇게 생각해요.
네.
그래서 명사형인 clarity가 있고, 무언가가 clear하다는 것은
형용사입니다.
네.
좋습니다.
그럼 먼저 주장의 구성 요소부터 시작할 수 있습니다.
주장의 다른 부분들이죠.
그리고 이것은 우리가 배울 수 있는 것입니다.
그리고 학창 시절, 에세이를 쓰거나 그런 것들을 했던 날들을 기억해보세요.
에세이를 어떻게 구성하나요?
글을 쓸 때 무엇이 먼저 오고, 그 다음, 그리고 마지막에 오나요?
여기 이 부분을 읽어봅시다.
이 단락을 읽어주시겠어요?
네.
잘 만들어진 주장은 잘 설계된 구조물과 유사합니다.
견고한 구성 요소와 매끄러운 연결이 필요합니다.
응집성은 아이디어들이 논리적으로 연결되도록 보장합니다.
반면 유창성은 독자가 주장을 매끄럽게 따라갈 수 있도록 합니다.
네, 훌륭합니다.
그래서 이 아이디어를 기하학적으로 보여주기 위해 이 이미지를 만들었습니다.
그래서 우리는 주장이 완전하다는 아이디어를 가지고 있습니다.
하지만 주장은 완전할 수 있지만, 흐름이 좋지 않을 수 있습니다.
주장은 모든 부분을 가질 수 있지만, 그것들이 제대로 연결되지 않을 수 있습니다.
그래서 이것의 각 단계를 살펴보면, 처음에는 잘 연결되지 않은 몇 가지 요소들로 시작한다는 것을 알 수 있습니다.
그것들은 우리가 필요로 하는 논리적 연결을 통해 연결되지 않았습니다.
형태를 갖추기 시작하지만, 좋은 흐름이 없습니다.
그리고 흐름이 개선되면, 완벽한 원으로 끝납니다.
그래서 이것은 응집성, 즉 전체적으로 완전하다는 아이디어를 보여줍니다.
이 그림의 육각형은 응집성은 있지만, 흐름은 없습니다.
반면에 이 원은 응집성과 흐름을 모두 가지고 있습니다.
그럼 어떻게 그렇게 할 수 있을까요?
어떻게 하면 우리의 단락과 에세이를 구성할 수 있을까요?
그것이 정리되고, 필요한 모든 부분을 포함하도록요.
그리고 한 부분에서 다음 부분으로 논리적으로 전환되도록요.
그리고 만약 우리가 그것을 제대로 한다면, 효과적으로 한다면, 우리는 그 두 가지 요소를 모두 갖게 되고 우리의 주장을 강화하게 됩니다.
그래서 우리에게는 이러한 논증적 요소들, 즉 퍼즐 조각들, 응집성, 즉 연결 구조, 그리고 유창성, 즉 아이디어 간의 매끄러운 흐름이 있습니다.
네. 그래서 우리는 주장의 이러한 핵심 구성 요소들을 기억해야 합니다.
여기 이것들을 읽어봅시다. 이것들을 읽어주시겠어요?
네. 처음부터 읽을까요?
주장의 핵심 구성 요소 상기하기, 주장, 사실, 배경, 논지,
주제 문장, 증거, 예시, 잠재적 반박,
그리고 결론, 이 요소들에 대한 확실한 이해가 기본입니다.
아주 좋습니다.
그래서 우리는 'claim'(주장)이 있습니다. 'claim'의 다른 말은 'thesis'(논지)입니다.
우리는 'background'(배경)가 있는데, 이것은 우리가 이야기하고 있는 것의 맥락입니다.
만약 우리가 이야기하기 시작하고 주장하기 시작하는데, 아무도 우리가 무엇에 대해 이야기하고 있는지, 그것의 배경이 무엇인지 모른다면, 그것은 명확하지 않습니다.
그래서 우리는 'claim'(주장)으로 시작합니다.
그것에 대한 배경 정보를 좀 줄 수 있습니다.
그리고 나서 우리는 'thesis statement'(논지 진술)를 갖습니다.
이것은 기본적으로 우리가 상대방을 설득하여 믿게 하려는 전체 내용의 주요 주장인 논지 진술입니다.
그래서 설득한다는 것은 다른 누군가를 설득하여 무언가를 믿게 하는 것입니다.